well professor of law here at the law
school and this morning's talk as I
assume you've seen already is entitled
democracy's a choice books or bumper
stickers
I choose provocative titles
intentionally and because of the
provocative they're also obscure and I'm
free to talk about pretty much whatever
I am whatever I want
actually what you'll be hearing from is
a version of a work-in-progress I'm
working on a book about things democracy
needs more of and needs less of and
books and bumper stickers play an
important role in the book that I'm
writing the role is partly literal but
it's partly metaphorical that is I'm not
saying literally there should be no
bumper stickers in a democracy we need a
law or that everybody needs a certain
number of books but there are aspects of
books and bumper stickers that represent
certain trends in our democracy one
positive one negative and I'm all for
encouraging us in a positive direction
I've been told by those who listen to
this talk that I'm oddly optimistic
given the trends that I cite I hope
you'll find that that is so you can tell
me what you think well certainly have
time for questions when we're when we're
done but to begin my talk I need to say
a few words about democracy itself
because the word that's used a lot and a
lot of us mean different things when we
say democracy so it's useful to think
about what it is that we mean a lot of
us identify amaq receipt ematic aliy
with voting but this can't possibly be
correct there are plenty of countries in
the world that vote and most of them are
not democracies in the last election in
Iraq before the government was
overthrown by the invasion Saddam
Hussein received a hundred percent of
the votes not ninety six percent or
eighty four percent or seventy one
percent but 100 percent of the votes
cast they had an election not
recognizably democratic there was a
country in the former Soviet bloc that
when it decided to have its first
election first western-style elections
throw open its doors
Western observers to come and see the
election and one of my colleagues here
at Yale was an observer of that election
and later came to give a talk to us
about what he'd observed he was situated
in a polling place he said where these
people most would never vote in their
lives arrived in the polling place were
given a secret ballot in a sealed
envelope and they went into a sealed
room to fill out their ballot sealed it
back in the envelope came back into the
main room and then for ease of counting
dropped it into one box of the drop
voting for one party in other box the
one of the other party and and so on and
part of his point was that he didn't
think that this had been consciously
designed by the government as a tool of
intimidation if they had just never done
it before it seemed to make sense to
them as an easy way to count the ballots
well whether that's true or not I think
we would not recognize it as a
democratic election it's important to
think about what a democratic election
is because it important to think of the
answer the simple question of why vote
every year at election time especially
presidential election time some of my
students come to me and there's a
professor Carter we're not gonna be in
class for the next two weeks because
we're gonna be getting up the vote at
Ohio or Pennsylvania and I say what you
think if you go to your law school
classes the fewer people will vote in
Ohio and Pennsylvania they say yes
absolutely they say what if the election
comes down to that one last bus that one
last van carrying people to the polls in
some suburb and I say no presidential
election has ever come down to that one
last van and one lap but nevertheless
they so they go off and they do what
they think is important it's not an
excused absence but that's another story
they go off and they do what's important
and then they come back and I ask them
do they have fun and they say oh it was
great fun and I say did you influence
the election I said of course if not for
us it we've gone the other way and so on
us and people like us they mean and then
they ask me what I think and I say well
you know I don't really like to vote I
don't vote unless my wife drags me to
the polls and makes me vote and they
said oh I don't like voting as well
first of all it's a waste of time that's
what he means a waste of time so what my
vote doesn't make any difference
I live in a small town and even in my
small town where I live no election
since I've lived there and I've lived
there now 15 years has ever been decided
by one vote therefore it makes no
difference if I vote or not and they say
well that can't be right what if
everybody felt that way
I said everybody doesn't feel that way
that's why I'm free to not vote if I
don't if I don't want to and then they
say well you know if you don't vote you
can't complain about the result and I
say watch me and they and they give me
these various reasons to vote and what's
interesting is that it's actually
although most of us think of voting we
conceptualize there's an obligation it's
not that easy to articulate the reason
we ought to vote so I'm going to give
you what I think is the one reason to
vote in a democracy and I want to
suggest to you that is this reason that
makes democracy different other forms of
government and then a tease out the
implications of that reason this is the
one reason when I vote I am saying to my
fellow citizens we're all on the same
footing we're all in some sense equals I
respect you across our differences and
therefore to show my respect as a symbol
of my respect I will take the most
cherished issues the things I care about
the most and lay them on the altar of
democracy invite us to vote on them
provided you will do the same and I will
stand by those results if you will stand
by those results that's what makes
voting in a democracy it's important the
voting itself isn't important because
the winning isn't important in democracy
winning is not a virtue winning is the
outcome of the exercise of other virtues
what's important about voting and
democracy is what it symbolizes what it
symbolizes is our mutual respect is our
feelings about our fellow citizens
without that mutual respect we may vote
but we are not really doing democracy
whatever else it
maybe that we are doing alright so at
this point you're entitled to ask what
on earth does this have to do with books
and bumper stickers well I'm gonna tell
you what I was doing books and member
stickers and the first thing I have to
tell you is I like books and I don't
like bumper stickers but you might have
gathered that already from the title now
I'm biased I write books I like writing
books I like reading books alright I
admit my biases I've written let's see I
think I've published 11 books most of
them on nonfiction a couple of novels
but the thing that's really important
about books is what they symbolize and
the things that thing that's really
important well bummer stick is what they
symbolize let's do bumper stickers first
what is the first thing we know about a
bumper sticker that it's on the back of
the car it's on the back of the car no
think about that for a moment to put a
bumper sticker on the back of the cars
to make a statement the statement is
this is true and it is so true that I
have no interest in anything you might
say to the contrary
moreover gonna force you to look at my
view but I have no interest whatsoever
in yours so from the beginning the
symbol can be undemocratic I don't mean
a bumper sticker can't be clever I was
once I think I was in Tennessee and I
spotted a libertarian I I think was a
libertarian bumper sticker which made
actually a really very sophisticated
argument in just two lines it says
something like I don't remember exactly
there's something like I'll keep my laws
off your body if you'll keep your laws
off my money or something like that
that's a thoughtful argument beware I
may be wrong but it's a clever argument
but I was still bothered by the fact
that it's on a bumper sticker the point
about what a bumper sticker symbolized
is it the bumper sticker symbolized the
notion that the complex issues of the
day can be reduced to simplicity to a
quick and easy line why does that matter
well one of the great historians and
political theorist of the 20th century
was Richard Hofstadter
he wrote two monographs very thoughtful
ones one in the 50s and one in the 60s
that bear on this the one in the 50s
which was a book was entitled anti
intellectualism an American life the one
in the in the 60s which was has been
published in before Matt it's really a
long essay is entitled the paranoid
style in American politics each of these
pieces in a different way made the same
observation the observation was this and
he looked out on America of the fifties
or sixties he argued America was divided
into two camps there was one camp that
he called progressive and what
distinguished the progressive camp was
its respect for reason and tolerance and
dissent its belief that what mattered
was the argument and that it was wrong
to attack one's opponents versus the
other camp which he called reactionary
which believed he said in applause lines
slogans emotional appeals and lists of
people to hate applause line slogans
emotional Appeals list of people to hate
and in both of these pieces he argued at
great length for why democracy needed
the first kind of person not because of
the policies these progresses favored
although he was a progressive himself
but rather because what democracy needed
was that belief in reason and tolerance
without that he said you couldn't have a
democracy you simply had mob rule and
one of the problems the proliferation of
bumper stickers with a quick easy line
about every issue Under the Sun is that
it plays into that second model of a
reactionary politics a politics as
Hofstadter said of slogans applause
lines emotional appeals and lists of
people to hate Hofstadter thought
democracy could not long survive if that
side became ascendant and one of my
great fears about politics today about
political life
and indeed about our democracy today is
that that site is ascendant on both
sides of the aisle that is to say that
we live in an era where every issue on
both sides seems very quickly reduced to
applause lines slogans emotional appeals
and lists of people to hate that is the
metaphor that's what I'm representing
when I use bumper sticker on the other
side is the book and that the book
represents first and foremost complexity
complexity a book by its very nature
stands for the notion that there are
issues that are difficult there are
issues about which one has to take a
long time to get a full understanding
especially books that are hard books
that are difficult books that are if you
will complex I realize that not all
books fit this description any more than
the bumper stickers fix the other
description but bear with me while I
pursue the metaphor a little bit further
in 1936 when fascist mobs were burning
books all over Europe the French book
collector
Maurice ro-bear trying to get them to
stop warned that your library said is a
mirror of your personality by what you
meant if you're burning the books quite
apart from the substantive issues that
tells us something about the kind of
person that you are fast forward to the
1950s and the publication of one of the
great novels of the 20th century Ray
Bradbury's Fahrenheit 451 now most
people are probably read fine at 451
when I talk about it in class most of my
students have read it but what's
interesting about talking to my students
about it what they remember out
Fahrenheit 451 is that it was a novel
about censorship of books that's how
they remember it and describe it that
way slightly mrs. Bradbury point which I
want to take a moment to articulate here
I saw most of you have read the novel
but if you haven't Fahrenheit 451 is set
in the near future remember was written
50 years ago
but said in your future it stole from
the point of view of a man whose job as
a fireman and the fireman intranet 451
of the ones who are called when books
are discovered and they burn the books
that's the job they burn them now what's
interesting about the book is that a lot
of the book is actually dialogue the
play interplay between Montag the
firefighter whose mind were in and his
boss the fire chief and what happens is
it's at one point Montag the firefighter
wants to know how did this book burning
business start anyway why do we do it
and there the fire chief makes a famous
speech in which he says it wasn't about
censorship
it wasn't about government control this
was a movement from the bottom up this
is a popular movement we burn the books
because the books are too hard people he
said wanted no complexity they wanted
their ideas simple and that's why we
burn the books the fire chief says what
traitors books can be you think they're
backing you up and then they turn on you
others can use them too and there you
are lost in the middle of the moor in a
great welter of nouns and verbs and
adjectives and he goes on to say books
remind us what asses and fools we are
they're Caesars praetorian guard which
brings the parade Wars down the Avenue
remember Caesar thou art mortal the
things you're looking for are in the
world but the only way the average chap
will ever seen nine and a percent of
them is in a book but books we said are
traitors
so the fire chief says the reason we got
rid of the books is that books can lead
you astray and they're not always on
your side
that reading a book the fire chief
emphasized and Bradbury wrote about this
later
can trip you up can change your mind
when you allow yourself to enter to the
complexity of an idea that complexity
changes you Bradbury's point was that
people wanted to live in a society where
nothing would change their mind where
their thoughts would never be challenged
well that's what Hofstadter in a sense
is talking about a world in which we are
never challenged a world in which we
spend their time with people who think
much like ourselves which by the way we
do spend their time not only in
organisations but in living patterns as
some of you may know recent data
suggests that far from red and blue
states or red and blue counties we live
on red and blue city blocks and suburban
blocks that actually literally blocks of
cities and blocks of suburbs are
identifiably
overwhelmingly Republican or democratic
in their voting habits we spend their
time around people like ourselves it's
better time talking to people who agree
with us partying with people who agree
with us reading the blogs of people who
agree with us watching the television
stations where the commentators agree
with us the more time we spend with
people who agree with us the easier it
is to look at those who disagree and say
that the solution is so obvious those
people must be fools there's a nice
simple reason that I believe X and if
you don't see it there's only one of two
possibilities one possibility is that
you are malevolent you're intentionally
not seeing truth the other possibility
is that you're not seeing the truth
because you're not smart enough either
way I don't owe you much obligation of
respect Hofstetter talked about this
particular problem
Hofstadter said that when ideas become
simple our divisions become greater
that's half started sever ideas
I'm simple our divisions become a
greater why did it become greater
because when the ideas are simple every
battle is a matter of life and death
that's what Hofstadter said because
there's the truth over here and the
truth deniers over there and there's
nothing in-between Hofstetter argued I
think correctly that only complexity can
wreck it can rescue democracy from a
situation in which we are hopelessly
divided because we look at those who
disagree with us and here we see not
opponents not critics but enemies now I
was a law clerk many years ago for
Supreme Court Justice Thurgood Marshall
and he got home a little bit then I got
known better the last year of his life
because the as some of you may remember
he retired in 1991 and he died just a
year and a half later but the Federal
Judicial Center asks retired justices to
do oral history projects and just as
Marshall asked me to be his interviewer
for their history projects we recorded
these tapes about his life we didn't
finish before he died but we got
probably between 30 and 40 hours of
tapes before Justice Marshall um died
and we gun what was I think the more
important part we didn't get much of the
Supreme Court era we got his earlier
life which actually is from the point he
hasn't any mind by scholars or later
biographers much richer and much more
important because you have to imagine
most people now who think of Marshall is
a great justice as I do or is a great
man as I also do they think of his vote
they look at the Supreme Court and the
opinions he handed down and so on but I
think that that to understand Marshall
truly and to respect control you have to
look at what was really the the better
story in a sense which was his life
before the court a life in which not
only did he litigate these civil rights
cases and criminal cases all over the
country for very little money often
literally at risk for his life trying
having to change cars to avoid a lynch
mob in one case lynch mob led by the
local sheriff
but also because the people he knew the
remarkable range of his acquaintances he
knew everybody
everyone who influenced 20th century
America in a great way seem to have been
someone he encountered and one of the
things that struck me both in the year
that I was one of his law clerks and in
the year and a half of the oral history
was how rare it was for Marshall to
speak ill of anyone of anyone I'll give
you one example of that the Supreme
Court decided Brown in its Board of
Education the desegregation case in 1954
now at that time Thurgood Marshall was
the lead lawyer for the plaintiffs the
parents wanted to send their kids to
integrated schools there were five
states that were on the other side three
southern states one Midwestern state in
one northern state that wanted to
maintain their segregated schools they
were worried they're gonna lose the case
they went out and hired the man
generally known as at that time is the
best appellate lawyer in America's name
was John W Davis a former a candidate
president United States a brilliant
lawyer a partner in a wall street law
firm who also interestingly was a West
Virginia and Virginia gentleman who
genuinely believed in in segregation so
years later actually this is when I was
one of Marshalls law clerks not in the
oral history I asked him about John W
Davis and I was about 25 26 years old
and therefore by definition knew pretty
much everything there is to know and so
I thought he would describe Davis in the
terms which I would have described him
at the time heaping Hellfire and
damnation upon his head but instead what
Marshall said I've never forgotten his
words with no trace of facetiousness he
said John Doe B Davis a good man a great
man who just happened to believe in that
segregation what it seemed to me that
Marshall was saying they're teaching
there and when he taught over and over
again if you look at the transcripts the
oral history which were all available at
the Federal Judicial Center in
Washington what he was saying over and
over again and particularly there was
that he was able across that great moral
divide to look at
those on the other side and see them
only as opponents rather than enemies to
see their common humanity this wasn't
just a matter of anesthetic it actually
made a difference in his work because
one of the reasons that I say he knew
everyone and reason the reasons that
matters one of the great untold stories
of Thurgood Marshall's life is the
amount of time he spent as he himself
described it in back backrooms playing
cards and drinking whiskey he would call
it with some of the leading
segregationist politicians of the age
senators governors mayors what he was
doing in those back rooms was making
deals making deals to avoid some kind of
disruption later on a lawsuit a
demonstration what-have-you
he was negotiating and he could
negotiate with him in part because they
didn't feel that somehow he was treating
them as less than human I want to drop a
footnote here I am NOT saying that there
are no issues on which the other side
has to be destroyed I'm not saying that
and yet I think each of us should have a
list of issues where we think there is
only one right side so genocide for
examples right up there at the top the
problem today is that we tend to have
lists not of one or two issues but of 30
or 40 issues a piece where there's only
one right side and you can't run a
democracy that way now back to the story
so that was the Marshall component now
some years after that are having to be
out in Aspen Colorado at lunch with the
retiring politician a member of Congress
he happened to be a Democrat that's not
important that story could he's easily
been a Republican this was in the 90s he
was retiring after a long life in public
service and he was in despair and those
of us were at lunch in them one nobody
was despairing about and he referred to
what he called the new
crowd in Washington and he meant
Democrats and Republicans alike and he
told us a story said back in the 60s
when he was cutting his eye teeth in
politics you could be on the floor of
house representatives make a fiery
speech about your opponent and that
night go out to dinner with them and
that weekend your kids would play
together and he said the difference is
with this new crowd again as referring
to both sides of the aisle he said with
them it's personal instead of them it's
personal they genuinely don't like each
other and that's why they can't get
anything done now he attributed their
not liking each other the fact they'd
never done anything together he kept
saying that his generation had gone
through depression and war and they'd
gone through it together so that you
knew the person the other side of the
aisle that's experienced life experience
is very similar to yours maybe that was
the reason but I was just another reason
that in the 1990s we're really seeing
the rise of simplicity simplicity as a
tool of politics really began seeing in
the 80s it accelerated the 90s and now I
fear that it is out of control I fear
that we live in an era now when it is
common to think of those that we
disagree not as opponents but as enemies
and either evil or stupid and to the
extent that we move into that world a
world of what the novelist John Laker a
memorably called
dangerous militant simplicity err
appalled if you're gonna get worse and
worse we have to find ways to resist the
notion that all is simple we have to
find ways to resist the notion that
there is no complexity or the complexity
is the enemy and I genuinely believe
that one of the ways or is that we
resist is through the medium of the book
now everyone in America of course agrees
we have a literacy problem we need more
people to be able to read that of course
is true but I'm speaking here not of
literacy but of books
actual physical books I mentioned a
moment ago that books symbolize
complexity the notion of a book is a
notion that someone believed in an idea
enough to create a form not easily
expunged it's not like a webpage where
you can make a mistake and go back and
take it down if you change your mind
you're stuck with an idea that's in a
book and you're stuck with it for all
time or until the book of crumbles into
dust
I'm not saying that all books equally
serve this purpose but all books equally
symbolize this purpose the notion of
complexity the notion that ideas are
hard and I think the more time that we
spend working our way through these
physical tomes the more time the more
we'll begin to respect the complexity of
issues which will lead us automatically
I hope to respect more those who
disagree with us now you might ask why
books rather than reading what
difference to make with you read a
physical book or a screen of text I'd
like to believe that it makes no
difference
I write in the online world too and I
certainly read there voraciously as I
suspect that most of us do but there is
growing evidence it's just evidence it's
not a certainty yet there's growing
evidence that it's not the same
experience there are a number of things
that are measurably different in
laboratory experiments when we read a
physical book versus when we read a text
online there was an early studies
suggesting that people don't retain as
much when they read a screen of text or
is a book but those have mostly been
over overturned it looks like at this
point we could fairly saying that people
retain as much with a book or with a
text online even getting to read the
text online because one of the problems
with text online it turns out is that
people don't like to read to the end if
you give someone a 7 to 50 page 750 word
op-ed that's a column in The New York
Times they'll read that the same op-ed
is at least two and possibly three pages
you got to click through a lot of people
read just the first page and then click
off to somewhere else so that's a bit of
a problem but if you can get people to
read this
the retention rate is about the same but
there are other things that are very
different in particular creativity
there's a lot of evidence originality
with little children that when you give
children a children's book to read it's
in book form and you give them the same
story on a screen they will retain and
understand the story just as well but
when you ask them to do something
creative with it the children who had it
in book form do much better so he asked
what do you think should happen next to
this little girl in the story or if you
were a character in the story who would
you want to be questions like that they
require them to interact creatively with
what they're reading the students who
read it in book form do much better now
the reason that matters these are kids
do the same studies as adults you'll get
similar results but with adults you can
say it's an artifact because adults are
accustomed to reading books they've done
all their lives kids were just learning
to read it turns out have exactly the
same problem there's a number of
researchers who believe that not only
creativity but imagination decreases
that in other words that young people
who tend to read online are not
themselves some researchers believe is
capable of thinking imaginative later on
they say to a child write a story turns
us children I've been reading stories
and book form can do that better than
children reading stories online now as
to why this is nobody knows as to
whether these result will hold stable
over time nobody knows but they point in
a worrisome direction because to the
extent we begin to lose the ability to
think imaginatively and think creatively
we may lose the ability to think
empathetically that seems to me to be
part of imagination what is empathy but
imagining yourself in someone else's
place and if we can in a democracy be
empathetic then it's even more difficult
to think that there could actually be
more than one side of a hot political
question what we might forget in other
words that sometimes the reason that an
issue is deeply divisive is because
people of goodwill can think about it
and come to different
conclusions sometimes divisive it's a
hard issue not biggest an easy issue in
which one side is right and one side is
just somehow idiotic there's something
else I want to mention also along this
line two more things that I wanna stop
and take your questions and comments a
number of libraries have stopped for all
intents and purposes functioning as
libraries they've been shipping a lot of
their books away the Yale wall library
keeps a much less of its collection here
to be browsed for example and some of
them are renaming themselves things like
resource centers information centers and
and things like that the problem with
this trend and I recognize the budgetary
constraints that create it but the
problem with it is once again it reduces
the idea of book to a source of
information that is if there's a book
you need you can we'll get it for you or
you can get this information online but
what makes libraries special is not
principally that their source of
informations that their sources of books
that there's sources of a particular
tool invented a thousand or so years ago
a particular tool that caught that holds
information in a particular form that
seems uniquely suited not only human use
but especially the needs of a democracy
it's quite striking that many of the
great thinkers of the 17 18 the 19th
centuries Diderot bacon there are many
others that someone in their careers
turned the question of how should we
organize and categorize human knowledge
what should a library look like that
question doesn't detain us as much
anymore many of you know that Google has
announced the intention of all of human
information online what I want suggest
that's impossible
you can put all every page of every book
online and that's not a bad idea
but it won't transmit the same
information as it does when you touch it
and hold it I happen to collect certain
antiquarian books and if I go into a
bookstore
and I pick up a a first-edition Sayyaf a
curry or Eliot that's a different
experience than simply knowing what
Thackery or Eliot said someone else held
this book and someone else before him or
her and someone else and someone else
and someone else I'm holding the object
through which others enjoyed the same
story the same argument the same
experience that I'm about to enjoy the
tangibility
of the book itself suggests ideas that
are important to democracy the idea of
permanence the idea of solidity the idea
of standing for the ages if we relegate
books in the end to museum pieces and we
relegate information to simply people
getting what they want in the easiest
and quickest way possible we will be
exceeding two great changes in what it
means to be a democracy the decline of
books isn't causing those changes but a
resurrection of books a renaissance of
books I think would help to slow them
and maybe even to reverse them because
we need I think to realize that vision
that Hofstetter presented 50 years ago a
democracy that believes in reason and
argument and tolerance of disagreement
rather than one that believes in
emotional appeal slogans applause lines
and lists of people to hate thank you
very much
no thank you
we thank you we have we have time for
questions if you have an I just ask
there's microphones here they're
recording this so if you can possibly
come to the microphone to ask a question
or make a comment I also ask that you
keep your questions or comments
fairly short in case so others can have
a chance and finally um be warned that I
will exercise my prerogative as a
professor to answer sometimes the
question that I wish you'd ask instead
instead of the question that you're
actually the question you actually asked
go ahead
you spoke briefly about Thurgood
Marshall socializing with people that he
was on the other side of the I think I
used the word socializing but but going
well I did you say gamble I'd like you
to talk a little bit more about that I
did say gilding of relationships in that
I'm sure the question is about yes I
mentioned Thurgood Marshall what I said
was was sitting in back rooms and
playing cards and drinking whiskey with
people with whom we disagree I I can
talk a little bit more about that a
couple of things I want to mention in
the oral history project one of the the
devices that I used very common for
interviewers we went year by year but as
each year or era came up I would throw
out names and simply invite Justice
Marshall to talk about those people as
he remembered them and one things that
was striking to me was the people for me
I defection yeah he he never said
anything bad about anyone with one or
two minor exceptions but I mean quite
famous that's quite famous liquor exam I
didn't like Malcolm X that's very well
known effective history and he didn't
say anything nice about him but that's
that those are fairly minor exceptions
but what was striking to me what I would
mention is who do you think is favorite
presidents were and he knew pretty much
all of them from the 1920s on several
presidents of course were Harry Truman
Lyndon Johnson and why Harry Truman
Elena Johnson well they were backroom
old-fashioned politicians with him you
could sit down and have a drink
and when he was striking about Marshall
when he talked about people he'd known
the highest praise that he would bestow
was you could do business with him
that's a you could do business with him
and all he meant by that
if you made it the only backroom where
anywhere else new shook hands his word
wasn't good so when he criticized people
who'd often quoted allows people for
breaking their word that was a big
problem for him when you would sit down
and make a deal and of course would do
something else instead from Marshall
that was a particular offense but my
main point in talking about Marshall is
not who we idolize me we didn't it's
rather this notion that that you can
actually have across great device not
ever great divine but across many great
divides you can have this kind of civil
discourse rooted in Marshalls case they
can actually human respect for others
now I want to make clear I don't claim
that I myself always share that but
that's my aspiration I think that's the
right aspiration to have but I also
emphasized what I said before I think
that it is it is part of the thoughtful
and reasoning person we should all of us
by our studies of history and the world
have a list in one of my books I think
my book on integrity says should be two
or three issues what you think there's
only one side and I think that's part of
being thoughtful
we shouldn't have someone once said be
so open-minded that our brains fall out
but went but Basel it should be short
because it makes it was long I worry
though all we're really trying to do is
avoid debate avoid facing up to the
possibility the people on the other side
may have a point
so again if you're talking about the
Nazis it seems to me you're talking
about the physical extermination of
other human beings
it seems be folly to pretend that well
maybe they have a point of view and we
need to listen to what they have to say
but I think list should be short
should be a very short one for each of
us it may not be the same for each of us
that's part of human diversity but it
should be a short list for each of us or
list you're not have ten or fifteen or
twenty different issues on it go ahead
yeah
on the one hand continuing use of kind
of jargon izing the political dialogue
that I see even the Obama administration
falling into
at the same time that clearly he is not
Dima fiying people in in the sense and
clearly looking to change the nature of
the dialogue in terms of making lists
about who you hate and don't get along
with I mean it I don't know
well as I said let me answer the
question that I wish you asked instead
let me slightly I think it's I'm
slightly restate the question I'm gonna
pretend that what you asked is are there
signs in the current era that make me
optimistic okay how about if we put it
that way
but the answer is yes but I have to
confess I see I'm optimistic in every
era I always see signs and people I say
man idiot that it things are just
getting worse and the rats have taken
over the ship and so on then where you
talk to in different years different
rats
according different people because I try
to hang out with people with multiple
points of view and so you know today I'm
with these people on the Left marma
these people on the right and I hear
so the difference tours before the rats
are but what's consistent is the story
so the rats have taken over the ship and
we're all going to drown unless we
overthrow them somehow or something now
here's the thing I I think that the
problems I've described are certainly
ingrained it's difficult to imagine a
single politician no matter how popular
or charismatic or single political era
overturning them let me give an example
of what I mean every four years we have
a presidential election we have these
things that's all I can call them things
that are called presidential debates
right now I would abolish these things I
would get rid of them they are not
debates they are joint news conferences
that are largely about the moderator
whose job it is to make sure the answers
are short enough to convey no
information whatsoever
don't you like you think about a typical
presidential debate
you say each I'm senator so-and-so
governor so-and-so tell us how you would
reduce the interest rate on our foreign
debt without raising taxes at home while
maintaining a reasonable balance of
trade a of 30 seconds that's what you
get in the presidential debates they
candidates barely have time to tell you
what their position is they have no time
to tell you why they believe it and
therefore they can never have the
opportunity to persuade you now you
might say well that's what their
speeches are for but it isn't it's not
what the speeches are for in fact it's
really quite striking if you read
presidential speeches as opposed to
listening to them you realize they are
virtually devoid of substance and
there's a reason for that it's perfectly
rational this is the reason in the 1980
election cycle the average presidential
sambhar in the evening news e by
soundbite what I mean here is something
very specific this is the amount of
uninterrupted time that you heard the
candidate in his own voice describing
his own views a clip from today's speech
was 42 seconds right in the 2004
election cycle the last words we have
data it was 7 seconds we gotta think
about that for a minute
that means that every speechwriter knows
that some 7 second snippet of this
speech is all that most voters will ever
know about therefore the candidate
cannot say anything remotely
controversial because one will never
hear the paragraph before and after only
hear only the seven seconds that's where
part of the problem lies that it's
become difficult to get information and
it's become so difficult that candidates
worry about the same thing on the web if
you look at the candidates websites in
the last presidential election one of
these that was really striking was there
were full of proposals but there were
very few explanations or justifications
to get for a few applause lines for the
proposals and there's a reason for that
it's not because the candidates are
idiots it's because they're smart
because they know
all the need is a an explanation that is
susceptible to being cut up in little
pieces and those little pieces will rock
it around the internet you see before
they can even before the old saying
before truth can get its get its boots
on now I'm a Lincoln
I like Lincoln I like reading amount
like and if you ever pick up the Basler
and the bachelors certain men it was the
the collected Lincoln works edited by
presser Basler if you look at the Basler
if you've page to the lincoln-douglas
debates you can easily find one of
Lincoln's answers went on for 13 pages
now it was different world people went
to political speeches for entertainment
there was no television there was no
radio there was no recorded music
I'm not saying F let people on for 13
pages but somewhere between 7 seconds
and 13 pages seems to me there's a happy
medium especially if if the news media
were actually be persuaded the important
part of the job is informing us about
what's going on tell you one more small
story about that I wrote a book many
years ago about the confirmation process
for federal judges and Supreme Court
justices and after I wrote the book I
met a retired reporter who had covered
third of Marshalls confirmation hearings
which were the nastiest I think in our
history but weren't on television I who
had cover Thurgood Marshall's
confirmation hearings a foreign major
newspaper and I had read his accounts
when I was working on the book and we
happen to meet socially and I said to
him you know I read your accounts and I
noticed there was a lot of stuff that
went on the hearing room that didn't
make it into your stories and he said
that's because in those days we had a
thing called news judgment now he
actually drew a link between the
coverage of those hearings in the
McCarthy era because this was the woody
this way put his point he said look
suppose you're sitting there in the
hearing room as a reporter and he hear
senator eastland call for the marshal or
communists right said well the thing you
put it in context Eastland calls
everybody a communist it's not
newsworthy
he said if you do the work and you
discover Thurgood Marshall is a
communist it's newsworthy even then
you've got a story Thurgood Marshall the
communist if you do the work and you
discover he's not a communist you got a
story
he's once a liar but if you don't want
to
do the work then you don't report the
allegation anyone on to talk about
peeled and destroyed by allegations
often 1950's and the press had been
going this period of soul sir he can
just stopped reporting his
unsubstantiated allegations which of
course isn't true anymore he said but
once television gets ahold of it you
can't you can't do that you can't make
those judgments so I was on a panel some
years ago about press coverage of
politics and I told that story and next
to me was a a famously muckraking
reporter was sitting next to me who was
next person along and I told this story
and he turned to me and he said that
this reporter who I didn't name was
wrong
he was just wrong it was not the duty of
the press he said to serve as a filter
like that my view is now what is the
duty of the press if not to make actual
news judgments but that was you know I
guess that was a different era an era
when news was carried by the printed
word yes right here and then I'll get
yours I see you've been waiting good
I'll offer you an observation and ask
for your comment because it's a brief
observation it's on your thesis because
I'm told we have to clear them exactly
11 o'clock seven minutes okay but good I
spent 12 years in Washington and a good
bit of it at the bars where the house
frequents which is both feathers now and
it used to be loyal opposition the other
side is the monocle and I observed and
see if it meets with you your thinking
as well that nothing got passed in
Congress until it had in fact been
reduced to a short statement on a
cocktail napkin by a committee chairmans
the cocktail party rule in one of my
books do you see the same thing that
simplicity is a problem in Congress not
just in the electorate well simplicity I
think that's a very good point
simplicity and complexity in Congress
play a very different role because
legislation tends to be enormously
complex but described in very simple
terms one of the promised reforms that I
really liked which hasn't fully
instituted by this Congress was to put
everybody's legislation online long
enough people actually just study it and
read it and understand it before it's um
voted on to in effect create a public
comment period we haven't done that
there been some but that's
a minority of pieces of legislation
there's always such a sense of urgency
only has to be passed today or tomorrow
which I don't fully understand it that's
forcing us by the 24-hour news cycle
there are very few bills that if you
waited a week to pass them some great
national disaster would strike their
song but I think you count them on one
hand something has to be passed today
instead of tomorrow
so it is true that what tends to happen
is the bills were all mostly complex and
the supporters and opponents go on talk
shows it's on and describe it in little
one sentence blurbs which are also know
if you like I'm going to read the bill
so not before it passes that's all that
we often hear about them I would not I
don't like that process at all yes
should torture renditions and the
invasion of Iraq be on our short list
and are they on yours I'm sorry torture
or those torture and logician and the
invasion of Iraq but I should be on our
short list um the question is the short
list you described no I just don't
you're saying um I'm not going to tell
you what should be intros I'm interested
in what should be another people short
list it strikes me I write and teach
about the rule of the law of war and the
ethics of war Just War theory and I'll
to speak to that one that while I myself
haven't been opponent of the war of Iraq
I don't agree with those who think that
was not justifiable there are certainly
justifications that could be offered
that's one of the weaknesses by there's
a footnote there one of the weaknesses
of international law with respect to
armed conflict is that the law is
sufficiently vague but actually justify
a lot of a lot of wars that the
international law is a very low
roadblock to fighting wars that's why I
teach a course on the ethics of war
because since we will never control war
through national law we have to control
it through a set of understood informal
norms and I'm innocent developing
informal norms of what war be I'm
working on a book now actual in which
I'm talking about
in fact the international law takes us
given that you can go to war to defend
your own country but it's skeptical of
claims of going where to defend someone
else so that if country
invades country beer when in Greece
going to be confined but if country a is
slaughtering its own people
international law says there's nothing
really country B can do about it and I
find that troubling if you look back to
one of the earliest writers in Just War
Augustin Agustin gave this famous
example he said suppose you're walking
through the woods and you're set upon by
robbers who mean to kill you and take
your purse he had you have the right to
defend yourself but you don't have the
responsibility to defend yourself you
can decide instead to say I will not
raise my hand against one of God's
creatures even to save my own life and
let me kill you then he says suppose
that you walk through the woods and you
see someone else is being set upon by
robbers said you have a responsibility
to defend that person that you are
claimed I will not raise my hands as a
Gustin can be used to add negate
self-defense but not to say of no
responsibility for going to the aid of
of another so you having this very early
writing about Just War the notion that
defending others is a higher claim than
defending yourself and it's been reduced
over the centuries or been reversed over
the centuries notion that defending
yourself is the highest and most obvious
claim and that's something that I've
written about and taught about and I'm
writing a book about actually right now
the right to protect under in the United
Nations is that something that you think
is the right to protect under law is it
developing um well no I'm sorry
mentioned national and they're going on
this road all right the right to
protecting international law there isn't
a right to protect real international
except to protect yourself there's a
Genocide Convention which requires all
the signatories to stop acts of genocide
wherever they are if you you may have
seen that wonderful if depressing movie
or Hotel Rwanda and there's the scene in
the movie Hotel Rwanda when the people
holed up in the hotel are listening to
the spokesperson of the Secretary of
State being asked by reporters is what's
going on Rwanda genocide and she keeps
saying well acts of genocide may have
occurred
there's
reason behind that the reason that she
put it that way is that if she said
genocide was occurring then the Unites
States would obligated by treaty to you
to put a stop to it the tree doesn't
specify force but it's widely understood
that's what a treaty means would July
never nothing's ever done under it no
country has ever acted on the genocide
treaty to prevent genocide in other and
in another country by moving it back to
the subject of books and and bumper
stickers yes right there in the
reduction to simplicity in politics does
wedge politics amplify it and then does
the big money amplify the wedge politics
in other words there's an investment and
the investors expected ROI right or
wrong true or false
where the question is on the question of
reducing its simplicity does wedge
politics change that in particular as
investment of money I'll make it worse
let me answer those questions reverse
yes
investment of money make it worse makes
it worse but I mean you do anything
about that I should explain and here I'm
in a minority in in the Yale faculty but
I'm probably as close to a first of them
an absolutist as exists on the Yale
faculty I really genuine believe the
government is no business except in the
most extraordinary cases interfering
with speech and so the notion that the
government can limit how much money
people can spend on campaigns here must
be of other people I I think it's
unconstitutional springboard disagrees
with me and they have more power than I
do so let's take it that I'm wrong but
I'm telling you my view on nevertheless
so the answer is IIIi think that there's
there's two different ways of looking at
the problem you've described is one of
the things that the investment of money
does is it allows people to run put
aside the influence of my last bill to
run commercials that oversimplify issues
enormous Lee and and these commercials
bother me even I think they're right
there on the right side I come urgently
on the right side and yet still be an
oversimplification that I think is
harmful to the notion of of dialogue in
a in a democracy so that's a just very
harmful and let me add let me talk about
one minor version of the first part your
question what about voters just care
about a single issue
what about you've got single-issue
voters out there then it's not that many
people study elections professionally
have discovered that surely the single
issue voter is largely a myth but there
are some and in a very close election
there may be enough to swing votes
especially in this last election it
looked like it's not entirely sure it
looks like this last election there were
a fair number of one-issue voters whose
issue was Iraq but typically the one
issue voters are on abortion on either
side by the way in fact a lot of
theorists think that the one issue of
pro-choice voters outnumber the one
issue pro-life voters whatever the
reason there are some one issue voters
out there and I think there's nothing
wrong with having some one issue voters
out there as long as there's a diversity
of one issue voters that is if every
voter is running on the same one issue
that's really bad but if you've got 50
different one issue coalitions that's
not a bad thing that's pluralism that's
what makes democracy work
ideally should be shifting coalition's
and people on this side on this issue on
that side on on that issue so you know
the pure libertarian who's would say
they're Republicans on guns and
Democrats on abortion or something like
that that's the kind of pluralistic
shifting coalition that's supposed to be
very important to make politics work
when coalition's become permanent when
they don't break up when they don't
fragment when the issues don't change
that's when 110 I think Tennessee
democracy break down even though voting
still works but the market needs to
break down at that point so we have time
for one more question if there is one
more yes right ma'am right there
yeah the question was if you didn't hear
it with the current media to which young
people are exposed blogging Twitter
television other things on being online
all the time how does one swim upstream
against it's very hard it's very hard
two quick things about that one is that
there are various estimates put aside
just the sheer amount of media that kids
consume they also consume a lot of
advertising along with that media by
some estimates as many as 3,000
commercial messages in a single day
depending what you measure as exposure
to and a lot of this is an area which my
wife who works in this area who runs
something called the motherhood project
I think it's recently been renamed
mother's for a human future has done a
lot of work studying the impact of
television well of advertising generally
on young people the impact is pretty
severe but all the data here the data
the most people I think probably already
know it's a big problem but all I will
say is the Pro it is a problem that it's
not resolved through abandonment of
adult responsibility you have to
recognize that we're raising the first
generation of young people that has
built its own subculture that is when
all of us are growing up it was
difficult to get to us for our friends
except through an adult all phones were
landlines are your parents know much
time are spent on the phone and often
they know who you were talking to on the
phone you want to go to your friend's
house your parents knew where you're
going when you're coming back and so on
with cell phones and various means of
online another digital communication we
live in a world in which world whatever
rules parents may think they're setting
about their household young people their
own subculture in which they communicate
and act together in concert without
regard to adult rules and that is
unprecedented in human history I'm not
saying it's a bad thing we don't know
yet it's one of those things I wish I
get to look at the answers in the back
of the book look at this generation and
its children and see you know I study
history and I'd like to look at the long
view I don't know what it's going to be
it's to be something different than what
we've been accustomed to before my hope
is that whatever world they build we
will help them build it in a way that
does not exclude the book as
the book is an enormous ly important
part of being a functioning citizen to
democracy again because of what it
symbolized I would like to see all of
the young people forced to make their
way through difficult books and write
difficult essays about them similar to
expose them to they have complexity
which an ideal without which I think
democracy can't function thank you very
much